Batman is perhaps the most well known
fictional portrait of a peak human
here's the ideal physical and mental
specimen he's a master of martial arts
he can chop down trees with his bare
hands he's strong enough to bench a
thousand or 405 pounds depending on the
writer he has a genius-level intellect
that he regularly uses to outsmart his
foes and he can run 20 miles averaging
450 per mile he somehow manages to train
vigorously to maintain this performance
patrol the streets for crime and still
keep Wayne industries running I analyzed
the Batman's training in depth in a
previous video and suffice to say it is
ambitious most of us don't have the time
to attempt it I would probably die
trying even if we did so the purpose of
this post is to try and scale it back
what would a Batman style training
program look like if it was designed to
be accomplishable for people who hold
down nine-to-five jobs if you have just
four to eight hours per week to train
how can you best utilize that time to
get to closer to Batman so a Batman
training program needs to be focused on
increasing our quickness our endurance
our strength our power our flexibility
and this is where a lot of people
struggle so you have people like Ross
ethically who demonstrates that you
really can build strength and endurance
at the same time here's a guy who's
climbed the equivalent of the height of
Mount Everest they're doing rope climbs
and a guy who has run a mouth and
dragging a car but we're going to take
this one step further by trying to
training like a Batman because we're
also trying to build in things like grip
strength things like flexibility things
like skill acquisition and hand-eye
coordination and balance and that's
where it goes from being a cross-modal
athlete into becoming Bruce Wayne
before I get right into it though I just
want to say that this is not a beginner
routine this is for more advanced
lifters people already have a good basis
of strength the foundation of mobility
it's designed to be achievable but it's
still pretty intense the first one we're
gonna run into is something called the
interference principle and this
basically states that when you train
hard in one area it's almost always
going to lead to deficits in another so
when you become much more explosive you
build your fast twitch muscle fiber but
as a result you might lose slow twitch
muscle fiber and become worse at
long-distance running
the other problem were going to run into
is burnout if we're doing all those
types of training things like grip
strength training which is really taxing
for the nervous system then you're going
to burn out really fast the first thing
that I'm going to recommend is smart
exercise selection in other words
choosing exercises moves that aren't
just targeting one thing but target
multiple things things that give you all
bang for your buck they give you
multiple benefits let you train things
like balance at the same time as
strength and performance so for instance
you can do a squat yes and a squat as a
fantastically functional exercise for
building a posterior chain but why not
do a one-legged weighted squat a pistol
squat with bare feet on the ground
outside that way your training your foot
strength your training your balance and
your training your legs and your
training your mobility so something like
that another one of my favorites is the
weighted monkey bar so I put a weight
belt on and then I do monkey bars
backwards and forwards that's fantastic
for your grip that's fantastic for your
core for your work capacity it's
actually very exhausting because you
keep going it involves in isometric hold
and of course it's a great lats workout
a great biceps workout other examples
something like bouldering rock climbing
that's fantastic for your grip for your
laps for your strategy for your cardio
your endurance for your legs even rock
climbing involves legs a lot more than
most people realize then you've got
something like heavy bag work this is
gonna build your cardiovascular
endurance but at the same time it's also
great for your shoulders your triceps
for your pecs
your core for your legs and if you're
throwing in kicks and things in there
and it's building flexibility and at the
same time it gives you a chance to
practice your martial arts technique
hands are fantastic they also build your
grip they also a great for your posture
your mobility and for your mental
insurance in your muscle endurance so
exercises like these that do lots of
different things all at once are
fantastic the next thing we need to
think about is how we're going to use
these so if you watch this channel
regularly then you know that there's a
big difference between doing very heavy
weights for just a few repetitions
versus doing lighter weight for high
repetitions this is a little bit bro
science II but there seems to definitely
be some truth even if the actual
explanation isn't quite right the first
kind will lead to myofibrillar
hypertrophy meaning that it causes micro
tears in the muscles builds mind muscle
connection causes more fast twitch
muscle fiber the latter kind will fill
the muscles with metabolites with blood
and that causes sarcoplasmic hypertrophy
filling the muscle cells with fluids
that uses for energy so doing those high
reps and those low weights is gonna
flood the muscles with blood cause the
pump and metabolites caused a lot of
hypertrophy also really good for feeding
the muscle tendon unit for aiding with
recovery for building vascularity for
increasing muscle endurance and it will
give us that Batman style look which is
also part of what we're going for here
so high rep low weight is important but
at the same time low rep high weight is
also really important because that
builds the mind muscle connection muscle
fiber recruitment improves our technique
it causes micro tears it builds fast
twitch muscle fiber all these things so
if you want to really perform and be
strong then you need to do that kind of
training too
fortunately they're already forms of
training that incorporate both of these
types into a single workout and that's
called a power building so it's people
who were interested in powerlifting and
bodybuilding they want to look good and
be strong as well and what they'll do is
they'll take those heavy compound moves
and stick them at the start of their
workouts and then they'll do the
isolated moves the curls your tricep
extensions at the end of the workout
when they're fatigued and when it
doesn't matter if they're not using
perfect technique anymore so they're
getting the micro tears and the strength
training and they're also getting the
pump and the hypertrophy at the other
end of the spectrum we're going to do
that we're going to take it one step
further so at the start of our workouts
we're not only going to do those
compound heavy lifts we're also going to
work on skills training things that
require a LOF not
for control so some of those old-time
strongman lifts that I've looked at
things like the vent press at the same
time things like the body weight skills
all of which require you to have all
your strength and all your control at
the start of the work out things like
planche things like bench press we're
gonna put them at the start of our
workout and then we're going to
gradually move more and more towards
lighter weight higher rep until we're
doing those isolation moves maybe we'll
end with some flush sets you know 20 50
reps even just flooding those areas with
blood the same areas we've been
targeting with those heavy lifts and
then at the end we're going to get over
them further we're going to move on to a
hay chai tea high-intensity interval
training finisher targeting that muscle
so if you've been doing a push workout
then you're going to be doing either the
punch bag heavy bag work in order to get
some cardio in there or you're going to
be doing some battle ropes but these are
still targeting the shoulders the
triceps the pecs the muscles you've been
focusing on if you're doing the pull day
then you're going to be doing rows the
rowing machine or you're going to be
doing fast pull-ups or the rope climbing
machine that kind of thing on leg day of
course you can do running or you can do
skipping etc kettlebell swings in terms
of intensity I want to talk a little bit
about what I call a dynamic drop set so
a drop set means that you're gradually
making the exercise easier so it might
mean that you're doing 10 of a really
heavy curl on the cable curl then when
you can't do any more you've put the
weight down and you carry on and then
when you reach failure again you put the
weight down and carry on this is a
bodybuilding technique I've talked about
it before it's fantastic for building
pump and for really encouraging growth
in the biceps whatever muscle you're
targeting my favorite type of drop set
is the mechanical drop set we're
actually changing the exercise so you
might do as many pull-ups chin-ups
rather as you can and then when you
can't do anymore you drop down and
you'll do some curls because they're
slightly easier than the chin-ups but
you can still do some more still
targeting the same muscles primarily so
that way you're able to go past failure
by it while still at the same time
changing your exercise I don't think you
should ever just do 3 times 10 of any
exercise I think that's a waste of time
involves a lot of waiting around and it
almost always means giving up whilst
you've still got some energy in the tank
so instead I recommend that you view
your entire workout as one set
in between all of these exercises you're
going to be throwing in mechanical drop
sets you're going to be including things
like the overcoming isometrics pushing
or pulling against the removable force
isometric holds just to finish it off
the burns which are just as much of the
repetition as you can do taking longer
rest times when you need them taking
shorter the best times when you need
them doing super sets that means
exercises back to back
miniature circuits so instead of seeing
them as separate exercises you're going
to go from your top really complex
movements all the way through to your
HIIT and whilst you're doing it you're
going to be mixing up the number of sets
and the number of reps you're going to
be pushing against unstoppable force
you're going to be holding weights in
place you're going to be doing just as
many repetitions as you can at times
you're going to be taking short breaks
long break is going to be doing things
back-to-back and whilst doing this
you're going to be targeting the same
kind of muscle groups and in a
functional and an isolated way and by
the end of it trust me it really hurts
yeah it's a shame but I'm obviously with
Tiger I mean he's kind of transcendent
gods idea also has similarities with
CrossFit so in CrossFit they're using
their compound lifts that deadlifts
their overhead presses etc clean and
presses and things like pull-ups but
they're doing these for really high rep
ranges to train their work capacity and
one of the criticisms across fit is that
as you get into the higher rep ranges of
something like a deadlift
you're going to start to see your
performance your technique deteriorate
and you increase your likelihood of
injury so we're gonna try and get around
this problem by combining things but
we're gonna put those technical and
heavy lifts at the start of the workout
while still being able to Train the work
capacity and the now build the blood
vessels etc but putting that at the end
of the workout with something simpler
[Music]
okay so that's giving you a clue as well
as to how we're going to structure this
program we're going to be doing a
push-pull legs routine except we're also
gonna do a four full body routine so I
call that ppl FB so ppl full body and
the reason for this ppl is really good
for both beginners and experts because
it gives you all your pushing movements
on one day or you're pulling movements
on another and all your legs on another
these obviously go together naturally
and at the same time it allows you to
really focus on those moves in order to
create the amount of intensity that you
need in order to trigger some kind of
growth some kind of strength gains the
same time you're giving yourself enough
recovery time to get better for the next
routine but you're also allowing
yourself to do this compound lifts which
you can't say do the splits because
you're doing pushing or pulling not just
the biceps for pulling meaning you can
do things like perps like monkey bars
etc
the only problem with ppl is that it
doesn't argue to train the same muscle
groups almost at all more than once a
week so a lot of studies are now showing
that it takes about 48 hours for us to
recover from a workout in any specific
muscle group and that training more than
once a week will allow you to see better
games better protein synthesis and it's
optimal so why wait a whole week when
you could be getting games faster but by
doing ppl and then a fourth full body
routine you can that way top-up to the
muscles and encourage a bit more protein
synthesis at the same time it gives us
the perfect opportunity to focus on a
kind of metcon workout metabolic
conditioning workout so that way we're
able to increase our cardio fitness even
more and we're gonna do a kind of
circuit and then I recommend you end
this with a four mile or a six mile run
because almost every time Batman's
workout is described it always involves
a bit of list and at the same time this
has got a lot of benefits to it helps to
strengthen and increase the size of the
left ventricle which lowers our resting
heart rate helps us to be karma and so I
really think there's a place for that in
your workouts as well
so you can find a example routine and
entire workouts over at the Bonilla comm
I'll put the link to that in the
description down below but you'll notice
that that's actually already slightly
different than the push day I just did
and so of course whilst I've wanted to
share with you an example the point of
this program and of this video is that
you need to adapt it to suit your
lifestyle and also just keep changing it
keep mixing up because variety is really
what keeps the body adapting and growing
and staying challenged obviously the
martial arts training we're getting at
the end of our workouts because we're
doing them during the push day for
instance but I also would highly
recommend doing a fifth day of some kind
of martial arts class in the week if you
can and if not then you can train on
your own I recommend watching grants
video on how to do that but you will
want some tuition to give you the right
technique to start with so that you're
honing and improving the correct
technique instead of the wrong technique
of course we also need a warm up and a
cool down I recommend doing foam rolling
or self myofascial release as your
warmup maybe some dynamic stretching and
I also recommend doing a body scan
meditation which I talked a little bit
about in my fashio video I'm gonna talk
about more in the future but it'll just
help to get you calm getting the right
state of mind for the workout whilst at
the same time increasing your mind
muscle connection highly recommended and
then at the end you can just do some
stretching because flexibility is also
important but we're also going to do
that on our D load week and one more
thing I also recommend that on your
fourth week you take a week off you take
a deal ode week and during this time I'm
not just gonna be sitting around you're
gonna do all that other Batman stuff
you're gonna focus on your skills
training so you're gonna do things like
reflex training you do things like
balance training jump height training
martial arts techniques you're gonna
learn new skills new information new
knowledge and I'll talk about these
skills training more but I used to do
skills training on a separate day during
my week but I found like always ended up
just putting it off and not doing it
because there's never enough time to
just spend the day throwing a ball
against the wall but if you do this on
your D load week and you focus on these
different skills and abilities as though
they were workouts
then it's a great way of doing it it
keeps you active when you're otherwise
twiddling your thumbs but it also lets
your body recover so you can do this for
longer when we're looking at the long
game here of course I haven't talked
about the mental aspect that I haven't
talked about the diet this is already a
long video so I'm not going to go into
it now I'm going to come back to this in
future but if you just want the cliff
notes for the diet what I'm doing and
what I think would work well for a
Batman workout of course making sure to
get a gram of protein per pound of
bodyweight at least because you're going
to need that for your recovery
I also recommend doing the strategic
intuitive eating that I talked about
before four days a week and on the two
more CV oriented days the metcon day and
the martial arts day which I talked
about on the website could also be
swapped out for a longer run I recommend
on those days you do an intermittent
fast 18-6 in particular watch my last
video on intermittent fasting for more
on that and how that works and there's a
lot of supplements I think could be very
useful
check out the supplement stack which
I'll link to in the description down
below as for the mental training of
course you have your D load week we're
going to be developing new skills but I
also recommend you do a morning routine
and that's going to involve meditation
image streaming writing with your left
hand in a journal and dual n-back
training but again I'll go into all this
in more detail in a future if that
sounds like something you'd like to hear
about
so if you only take one thing from this
I want it to be those dynamic drop sets
so just to properly explain once again
what that is basically a drop set is
where you keep going by lowering the
weight a mechanical drop set might mean
that you're changing exercise safe and
bench press to press ups the dynamic
drop set means that you're combining
both those things but you might also be
changing up the cadence for instance by
going from a overcoming isometric or
very slow five to five rhythm to a
faster more explosive rhythm within the
same set and then to extend that I want
you to think about your entire workout
as some kind of giant drop set so that
you're moving from more complex moves to
more isolated moves to the or mixing up
your rest time so that you're throwing
the hold three times ten out of the
window and one more way to explain this
is as a way to combine the three
triggers of games the muscle damage the
mechanical tension and the metabolic
stress so doing something like planche
is fantastic for mechanical tension but
you can't do it enough to cause the kind
of hypertrophy that you get from
metabolic stress so by combining two
different types of exercise by dropping
from something more complex and then
isolating a specific muscle when it's
already fatigued you're able to do both
of those things and over on the website
you'll find complete programs that you
can start using but the whole point of
this isn't that you follow those
training programs to a tee although you
can do that and I'd love to know your
progress if you do please share but that
you adapt these routines and you keep
changing them to fit your lifestyle and
also your circumstances there are ways
that you can mix these up so that
they'll work better as part of a home
workout you can mix them up so that they
use the equipment in the gym and I
might've got carried away there might be
too much there for you and it's fine to
drop some of those things out or swap
them out things that you prefer I'm all
the time thinking about things I wished
I'd included but the point is I can't
include everything without doing a whole
list of different workouts if you like
this kind of training the dynamic drop
certs the Batman routine the skills
training then stay tuned to this channel
cuz I'm going to be returning to this
concept a lot in the future in fact I'm
hoping to work on a book after I finish
my book the gig economy but
he tells this kind of training far more
in depth so if you'd like to see that
and if you'd like to see more sample
routines if you have any questions let
me know and stay tuned like I say this
is just the beginning of the Batman
training program thanks so much for
watching as always and thank you very
much to all of you who supported me over
on patreon the link to that is in the
description down below and I'm uploading
some exclusive content over there that
you can check out and I've got loads of
more cool stuff come to the channel soon
if you want to know more about that then
check out my 50,000 subscribers video
I'd like to say a massive thank you to
Patrick Reynolds who's been very kindly
creating some of the thumbnails for this
channel I think they look awesome
and I'll leave a link to his Instagram
in the description down below as well
you can buy some of his photography as
Prince they look awesome so highly
recommend them so thanks a ton for
watching guys if you enjoyed this then
please subscribe and I'll see you next
time
bye for now why is nobody fist bump me
yet